love this guy love his announcing love
everything about him he calls games for
the brooklyn nets uh locally in the new
york area and uh great job on cbs and
westwood one radio he and uh um
charles davis just a great team and
they're calling bill's patriots three on
cbs this weekend iron eagle back here on
the rich island show how you doing
hey rich congratulations on you on what
i mean just hosting the oscars
degeneres goldberg
hope
niven
eisen
you forgot i think you forgot franco uh
franco
that's right
martin baldwin
i had a short in my list rich we only
have a certain amount of talk
i fear like this is kind of like uh the
nfl you don't talk about fight club if
you want to get in fight club but i'm
going the opposite approach i'm just
going to say
i'm assessing it you know i'm i'm like
robert hunt you know what i mean i'm
like robert hunt like this may be there
may be a flag on the play but i'm going
to try and score you know what i mean i
did call that game you did right tucker
and i
had that game on thursday night miami
baltimore and ross
was laughing like a wounded hyena during
the entire call that's how giddy he was
at what transpired with robert hunt
making his way instinctually grabbing
the ball and going towards the end zone
it was tremendous it was like the
football version of because stanza
trying to show up the day after he quit
you know like it's like we all know in
the room this can't be but you're gonna
be right why not right why not keep
trying that was incredible incredible
great it was one of the wacky
wacky plays of the year and it's a very
unpredictable season that you've lived
every pulsating moment of we hit the
postseason
and now the question is does it go
according to chalk or do we still get
some of this
unpredictable vibe that has permeated
throughout the regular season into the
playoffs i agree uh ion eagle i agree uh
so you and charles are set for
bill's patriots three
correct
yeah i mean not not the best sign that
middle of the week instead of the the
deep preparation that i normally put
myself through
i'm googling
how to stay warm
outside
during sub-zero conditions like that
literally this morning i woke i'm like
you know what i need a game plan
and
i got nothing really from the internet
like cover every bit of your skin yep
thanks i kind of knew that one i i um
honestly i don't want to psych myself
out so i'm just going to go into it i'm
going to i'm going to go through my
normal rituals my normal my normal
physical
and mental prep and just hope for the
best
saturday night there's many different
things to go here so i'll just go
directly into it so uh
now
there's no choice for you to leave the
window of the booth shut up no choice
why because because there are monitors
hanging out the edge of the window or is
this a pride thing is what is it
yeah i would say
it's 50 50 it's the logistics of it you
need the open window for wires for
monitors and then the other half that
you just alluded to
yeah it's a pride thing you can't be the
guy 30 years from now when they say i'll
remember the coldest day for a football
game since the ice bowl
i don't know we closed the windows
you can't
why
why it's self-preservation
come on
bridge you can't
whatever i need to do
to try to bundle up but i'm not going to
be the guy that was toasty warm wearing
a
v-neck t-shirt during new england
buffalo because it got too hot in the
booth
i don't know if you saw the last episode
of curb or if you've been up on it but
it's just is this like larry david
roping off his director's chair like you
like you would you'd receive the scorn
of everybody in the industry and they'd
all look at you as the guy who shut the
window is that what you're saying
would lose all respect
i could never live with that on my
conscience
it's like roping off the chair you can't
do that space heater though yeah yeah
basically no environment wait a minute
kurt warner's jacket
there you go
there you go i don't think you're using
it he's with me in studio
yes the silver puffer comes out
yes i will go full michelin man yes
the jacket there you go cause kurt kurt
trended too i don't know if that really
matters to you uh i saw it no i you know
it matters it matters a lot
kidding me i i want to be compared to
a bite-sized hershey's kiss during a
national broadcast of an nfl game that's
the kind of that's the kind of reaction
i'm looking for no i i heard space
heaters that that's possible okay
we're gonna look into whatever we need
to to make sure we're comfortable during
the game the reality is this this is a
secondary story rich yes i know some
people want to make it the least
let it become the lead it's a secondary
narrative
that's just you being the professional
that you are uh
if i am not mistaken you and charles
called the second part of this trilogy
correct did you call that we did okay
yeah it was a a masterful josh allen
performance when he
truly had command of the game it just
felt like from the word go he was locked
in on beating the new england patriots
that day and
changing the perception of the way
people viewed the afc east this year
you know what the expectations were for
buffalo entering the season this team
was looking at a super bowl or bust
mentality after what they did last year
afc championship game appearance lost to
kansas city same group back felt like
they were ready for an extended run
and they really struggled early in the
season
and i think people then stopped paying
attention to them for a while until they
went back into the lab and got their
their whole game in order where now you
look at it and say wait they can come
out of the afc they're just as good as
anybody else they're probably the most
balanced team in the afc if you go
player for player and what they bring on
the defensive end and the dynamic
offensive
skills that alan brings to the table so
to me this is a strange thing to say
compared to where they were a year ago
because we had the
playoff game last year the wild card
game against indianapolis right i
actually think buffalo is in a greater
position this year
after having such a tremendous regular
season last year breaking through
winning the afc east i like their team
more today
than i did a year ago why
i just think they're now prepared for it
they realize what goes into it they've
experienced some adversity they've
gotten through that period i think
they've exhaled a bit
over what was for a moment
a stretch where they could have been the
biggest underachievers in the nfl and
they they got through it and now they're
better because of it they've got more of
a running game right now than they did a
year ago
devin singletary has been a factor down
the stretch this season their defense is
tremendous leslie frazier sean mcdermott
that group has been excellent they lose
and a pro bowler and tredavius white
they've lost nothing on the field
somehow that's not saying they're better
because of it they're not but dane
jackson has held down his spot levi
wallace has been excellent taryn johnson
is very opportunistic and seems to have
a nose for the ball i just i like their
team i like where they stand right now
well and then they're it's amazing how
you could say that the patriots are the
less experienced right i mean certainly
with that head coach who's been there
and done that uh we don't need to go
into belichick's resume clearly but uh
when you spoke to mac did you get to
speak to mac jones because i know that
the patriots have definitely not
presented him to a lot of broadcasters
so did you get to did you do we do talk
to him okay uh each week our scheduled
meeting is tomorrow and he's actually
been very good in the meetings i think
the patriots like
a lot of teams with rookies that are in
prominent roles try to pick and choose
their spots and they're easing him into
this position he's got a lot on his
plate yes but i gotta tell you he's
really likable when you talk to him oh
sure he's yeah he's he's got a really
good way about him he's highly
competitive he gets very very hard on
himself when he makes mistakes i think
that's been out there as part of the
scouting report but
good dude likeable dude he's going to be
doing this a long time in a prominent
position with the pats uh we will talk
to him tomorrow yeah because i mean you
obviously you know that win streak that
the patriots went on
that seven gamer that that basically got
him in the playoffs
um and that the seventh consecutive win
was the first visit that the patriots
made to buffalo and we all saw what
happened on that monday night game with
the weather in which he only threw it
three times and then comes the bye week
and he has not been the same i mean at
all i mean the colts he did have a
terrific fourth quarter to make that a
game on that saturday night after the
bye week then the second buffalo game in
which he really had a long afternoon we
can just take the jacksonville game and
throw that one out although the colts
would love to do the same with week 18
and then the game against miami so what
what do you think is the concern what
were you hearing i guess a couple of
weeks ago what are you sensing prior to
your conversation with him getting ready
for the playoffs
yeah i think there's always a concern in
terms of the
the rookie wall that takes place for a
lot of these guys i know he played at
alabama which means you you're playing a
whole bunch of games he didn't start
every year at alabama we know his story
that he waited he waited he waited he
got his opportunity obviously did a
great job under nick saban
but for all of these rookies when you
get into december and now january
there's always going to be a concern
that they just don't have as much gas in
the tank
and the other part of the equation is
pretty simple there's more tape there's
more film on you defensive coordinators
are really good in this league at
picking out where
you are susceptible and where they can
expose you
out on the field and defensively the
patriots haven't been very good in the
last month so that hasn't helped either
i think there were probably a couple of
games in that seven game winning streak
where the defense was just so dominant
mack didn't make any mistakes and they
walked out of places with a win
and it just gets coupled together when
you rip off so many wins in a row you
just assume everything is clicking all
at once
not necessarily the case but
rich you know and i know that rookie
quarterbacks in the nfl have had very
limited success from playoff time that
just
doesn't happen even the great ones
struggle
in those spots uh the last three to win
games in the nfl as a rookie in the
playoffs you've got mark sanchez you've
got joe flacco you've got ben
roethlisberger
no rookie qb has ever won a super bowl
and there's a reason behind it it
requires reps experience life experience
doing this job and
mac is no different you could say the
same thing for first-time quarterbacks
in the playoffs as well and that's where
burrow and also derek carr
fall under that uh umbrella jalen hurts
in the nfc um you know
and and so on and so forth um uh iron
eagle here on the rich eisen show uh
before i let you go uh i just want to
tap into your nets
world a little bit here why did the nets
eventually decide half of kyrie is
better than none after they said
otherwise prior to the season i think
their decision was made when kovid hit
the team and was hitting teams all
around the league and they looked at
their roster and they said okay
what are we doing here we've got a
ferrari in the garage that we're not
willing to drive even on a part-time
basis do we need to reassess our stand
on this
and they tried to look at it logically
they took the temperature of the team i
believe kevin durant was vociferous in
his opinion that he wants kyrie out
there even if it's on a part-time basis
and ultimately
that's something you have to consider
when your star player the guy that
you've built your team around in kevin
durant feels very strongly about
something you've got to listen as an
owner as a gm
as a head coach so i think there were a
lot of factors that went into it but the
main one was the team is flawed and they
believe that kyrie would make them
better they're trying to figure out
exactly how this is gonna go i think
there's still a part of them that
believes eventually he'll play in home
games but getting to that point it's
been a
very circuitous route to get there in
the new york city mandates and then
kyrie's own personal beliefs right so
that that the way around it would be i
guess what for him to either take the
shot or move to pennsylvania and
helicopter in
i mean seriously the second part trust
me they they were very much aware of i
think there's a faction within the team
when the mandates came down initially
they read through them and this is going
back to late summer august september
before it was even public
it looked like there would be a loophole
a caveat that if you're not a new york
city resident this would not apply to
you kyrie irving lives in new jersey
that is his state of residence so there
was a short period of time where both
the nets and kyrie and his people
thought okay this doesn't apply to him
he's going to be fine and then about
seven or eight days after they got the
initial paperwork there was a an
addendum of some sort from the mayor's
office saying no no no no no that
includes the tri-state
new york
new jersey connecticut if you work in
new york city on a quote-unquote
full-time basis so the goal post
definitely shifted from the initial
contact and i do think that's why the
nets and kyrie thought this was going to
be pretty much irrelevant when it first
came down at least behind the scenes
iron eagle thank you for the time sir
greatly appreciate it um as a thank you
because we always try to leave you
better
um even though you can't see this
we have done this and i will text it to
you uh the crack staff to use the marv
phrase um
here at the rich eisen show have put
your head on
uh kurt warner's jacket
seamless
it's not as bad
as you think
it might be
i'm just saying
uh you should leave the door open a
little bit here you know rich
you're in contact with kurt on a daily
basis
he's willing to send me the jacket
i will wear it as an homage in addition
it's self-preservation the thing looked
warm as hell it was taking in whatever
sunlight there was yes it was it was
beamed into the jacket for extra warmth
so solar powered it's a solar-powered
yes
i'll go there like i don't care about
being mocked electric blanket or maybe
that costanza russian yeah
like one of those
turned out to be a rat though that was
bad that turned out to be we can't have
that but my concern though also uh ian
for you is uh does the cbs crest have to
be stitched on it
no at this stage i think it's it's every
man
for themselves i'll wear a babushka you
want me to wear a babushka i'll wear a
babushka whatever it takes to do
whatever it takes cause you gotta it's
all about bringing your a game so
branding cbs branding be darned you
gotta be warm i'm calling kurt uh during
the commercial break
because he lives in arizona his i i know
his schedule
he's doing he's doing two studio shows
here in los angeles and then he's
sticking around he's doing the westwood
one broadcast of the monday night game
from sofa he does not need it over the
next week taylormade this is this is set
up for me there it is i don't i don't
see any other purpose other than going
to the smithsonian
what else are you doing with that canton
canton require it canton that's where
it's got to go okay
thanks for the call you take care
all right guys all the best send me that
pic i need that it's coming it's coming
up on twitter right now well i mean i'll
send it to you too if you could use it
for your own purposes do you take care
of that george burns that was the other
host i was thinking
in
in man don't you know that the campaign
has just begun for me to host the oscars
i'm pushing the east coast they're going
to know about this thank you very much
iron eagle everybody from uh cbs and uh
yes as well
okay send me that photo i have to send
it to him and i'm calling kurt right now
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here